if you are hosting a party at your house
for the fourth of july there are some
things you should keep in mind to ensure
you are being a good neighbor and here
with some special tips is hoa expert
mary radina and she has a special guest
with her mary tell us who you have with
you this is nova grace my six-year-old
granddaughter nova you look so festive i
love your dress and your flag
thank you
all right so a lot to talk about
obviously fourth of july is a great time
to hang out with friends and family
maybe have you know a backyard barbecue
but what are some tips and things that
we should all think about before hosting
a big soiree well as we know las vegas
is a 24-hour town so we should be
mindful of our neighbors who may be
working a leadership or having to get up
early in the morning um also for those
that have pets or some of the elderly
may be a little fearful of the loud
noises so just be a little considerate
and think about that when you're hosting
your party outside and then when you're
done shooting off your fireworks go back
inside or in your backyard wherever you
are celebrating just so you're not
loitering in the street you don't want
anybody to get the wrong idea and call
the police on you and you know ruin all
of your fun
and if you are planning to host a party
do you recommend maybe talking to your
neighbors first before doing that or how
do you approach that absolutely let the
neighbors know that you're going to be
out there maybe invite them to join you
you know if you do something on the
street and going to do the fireworks and
you know they've got children like nova
nova has a tip on what to do if you're
handling sparklers oh no though let's
hear your tip on sparklers i love
sparklers
so
for you you need to have the sparkler
but don't put it next to your face
because
you get burned in your face you can put
it far away for your double fate put it
water for the stick away
nova that is very smart and very helpful
because everyone's always playing with
those sparklers and you don't want to
have them too close to your face right
absolutely well thank you for that tip
and let's talk really quickly about like
music and things like that obviously
people like to keep the party going
through the night but you kind of
suggest once the fireworks are over
let's turn it down a bit absolutely
again like we mentioned you've got those
neighbors or maybe they've got like i
have got grandchildren and they go to
bed you know by a certain time at night
and you just want to be you know
cognizant and just be a good neighbor in
it and think about that yeah you know
everyone likes to have fun with
fireworks but it is always so
frustrating when you're trying to go to
bed after a fun night and two three four
in the morning people are shooting them
off so it's helpful to not necessarily
see it as a curfew but just as a way to
tone it down you know once the sun sets
right absolutely and you don't have to
live in an hoa to be considerate like
that or it's pretty much i think
ordinances throughout the city after
certain time of night well thank you
guys so much for breaking this down this
is really important to keep in mind you
know during especially a fun holiday you
want to enjoy but also being safe nova
thank you for your tip can you give us a
little wave with your american flag i
love it you guys are so festive thank
you so much for being here we really
appreciate it thanks nova
all right well